[Music]
6 41 on a wednesday morning in this
week's vegas drives las vegas now's
rocky theist takes us to a destination
that feels like wine country mainly
because it is it's only about an hour
away from las vegas take a look
[Music]
it's time to wind down in perron
[Music]
well we were built in 1990
we opened in 1993.
we do make bottle and produce
more wine than any winery in nevada
combined we have over 3000 acres of
vineyards in the state of
one and nevada
half here on site which we grow
zinfandel syrah and how does the parrot
valley winery grow these grapes let's
head to the vineyard for a tour of this
lush land okay jennifer how old are
these vines in particular they're about
25 to 26 year olds in window vines
and dale and how do you have the water
here to produce
grapes like this in the desert well the
word for rump actually means water from
rocks so we get amazing groundwater that
the vines actually thrive on i did not
know that what else can you tell us
about the zinfandel grape that grows
here um they're a little sweeter because
you get a little blackberry hints into
it
um there's a lot there's more sugar in
these grapes than a typical like grape
so they are a little sweeter but it's a
nice red zinfandel these are syrah vines
and the flavors of that the flavors of
that well we have giant eucalyptus trees
above these surabines and the eucalyptus
trees get down into the ground and
actually get up into the vines so you do
get hints of eucalyptus when you're
drinking or syrah it's amazing that's
very unique yes it is that's unique to
you from valencia
yes so these are ready to go into into
the into the barrels where we separate
the stems from the grapes okay are we
stomping grapes they no we have machines
for that nowadays yeah
speaking of stomping grapes although
that's not part of the professionals
process it is part of the community's
fun coming up in october is good all the
family events start yes
yes we do our annual stompapalooza the
first weekend in october every year
um we do a lot of live a lot of events
during then we have vendors we have bars
set up outside live music
the grape stomp obviously it's the main
attractions a lot of it's a lot of
excitement there's prizes and games and
all kinds of fun things to do you have
to buy tickets and those are on sale
online right now or you can buy them in
on on property you can buy them here if
you come in to dine with us and
according to perrault residents diane
and john dining at the winery is a
special experience we love coming here
we love the people
they're very friendly the food is great
the atmosphere
the windows i mean it's just you can sit
here and relax as far as eating it's
this is the best place it's the best
place yeah different than anywhere else
you can enjoy breakfast lunch and dinner
at symphony's restaurant so in front of
you you have our meatloaf which is
carved from our filet that we do hand
carve it's ground filet mignon
it literally melts in your mouth it is
one of
my favorite dishes here that is so good
okay so what do you have i have the
shrimp scampi which is actually made
with the symphony wine
it's very unique it's got a little
sweetness to it because it's made with
like a moscato grape so it's a little
sweeter than your average scampi
but it's delightful oh and whatever you
do
do not skip the bread
oh my god then after dinner how about a
night cat you can taste three wines for
five dollars any free you want if you
want more than that then that's fine too
and one of them tastes like candy sweet
melody and that one is a gem
you would never guess but if you smell
it first you get hints of chocolate a
sweet melody for a sweet escape to
perrump i love it here right
cheers to the front valley winery